ciao marina este venuti in questo nuovo
mac tutorial vi piace trucco di oggi ci
ama rivers e benvenuti in questo nuovo
attesissimo oggi si parla ancora di
natale ma il particolare di make up me
l'avete chiesto da più o meno allo in
questo video finalmente è arrivato in
particolare ho voluto proporvi 3 make up
che se con me sono adattabili a ciascuna
di voi infatti è voluto proporre uno un
po più semplice uno un po più calcato
uno tipo natale a rio quindi vi potete
sbizzarrire partiamo subito dal primo
make up che come vi ho anticipato è
molto semplice molto basic con una nota
natalizia se no non avrei inserito qui
dentro è sicuramente il meno impegnativo
di quelli che vi proporrò quindi lo
potete utilizzare tutte quante iniziamo
dagli occhi allora per quanto riguarda
gli occhi inizierei a fare
un'ombreggiatura con un bel pesciolino
marrone molto chiaro però quindi
iniziamo appunto creando l'ombreggiatura
sulla palpebra fissa una volta che avete
finito insomma di applicare questo
ombretto sulla barbera fissa per quanto
riguarda la palpebra mobile invece
arriva la nota un po sberluccicante ci
sta a natale e io in particolare uso
questo qua lo andate ad applicare sulla
palpebra mobile e secondo me è l'effetto
che si viene a creare molto molto carino
e molto anche semplice vedete adesso
andiamo a sfumare
se questo trucco vi sembra un po troppo
chiaro nel senso volevate calcare un
pochino di più potete chiaramente con un
ombretto secondo me marroni marron
marrone scuro andate a creare l'angolo
il mostro occhio con questo veramente
poi andremo a sfumare
diciamo che faccio un occhio semplice
cioè un occhio senza il marrone e
l'altro con il marrone quindi ho fatto
un occhio più calcato e l'altro meno
strong però comunque è abbastanza basic
come trucco nel senso è una sfumatura
dall'oscuro al chiaro e passiamo al
mascara
vedete che comunque anche senza eyeliner
soprattutto nel caso di questo qui che
ho marcato ho calcato un po di più
l'effetto è carino per quanto riguarda
le labbra invece opterei per questa
tinta labbra qua subito vedere
ecco qua come avevo detto non è
impegnativa però è shining ed è perfetto
per il natale quindi questo è il primo
make up che vi consiglio chiaramente non
è un errore
per farvi capire che ci sono due
alternative in questo make up quindi ho
un occhio modo non che nell'altro per
questo motivo il secondo me i capi
invece è un pochino più carico un po più
impegnativo e anche per quanto riguarda
le labbra andremo a caricare un pochino
di più più carico ma non troppo abbiamo
subito dagli occhi
rimarrei sulla palpebra mobile con
dorato per gucci dino come il primo ma
andrei a diciamo sfumarlo con un mattone
rossiccio quindi andiamo sui toni un po
più caldi quindi iniziamo appunto con un
mattone
quindi tu in tendente al rossiccio un
aranciato vedete voi quello che avete in
casa che come abbiamo fatto prima
andiamo insomma riempire la fissa
andiamo sempre mar un po rimarrai sempre
su tonalità scure in particolare
qualcosa di un po più magari satinato
però sempre appunto tendente al
rossiccio andrei a scurire appunto sul
lato esterno dell'occhio
siamo arrivati al momento della palpebra
mobile io userò la quintana bra e lo so
fa ridere però viene figo l'effetto la
tinta una tinta labbra della knicks
molto molto carina e landro applicare
appunto
nello spazio che avevamo lasciato
secondo me essendo comunque una tinta
labbra lunga tenuta
magari per una bella serata in discoteca
o appunto una nottata lunga bicchieri
anche di più andate chiaramente poi sa
bene essendo lo meglio con un pennellino
e io direi che ci siamo l'effetto è
molto molto figo
passiamo al nostro amico non è la nonna
maria
poteva andare peggio eyeliner messo
passiamo a matita marrone leggermente
sotto l'occhio matita bianca dentro
l'occhio e passiamo al mascara tutti
gare sia sopra che sotto questo è un
primer
come le ho detto applichiamo anche un
perino di pescara sotto per quanto
riguarda gli occhi ci siamo passiamo per
concludere il make up a la tinta labbra
è un rosso però un po tipo tenente del
bordeaux con dei tipo brillantini dentro
ma molto molto delicato l'effetto
brillantinato non lo sei carino
ok tinta labbra ies a posto volevo
aggiungere un altro tocchino d oro
esatto quindi quello stesso posato per
l'ombretto della palpebra mobile lo
rendono leggermente per dare un po di
luminosità questo è il secondo make up
che voglio proporvi come vi avevo già
detto è un po più strong del primo ma
secondo me è estradabile a ciascuna di
voi perché se non vi piace l'effetto too
much e quindi tanto trucco potete o
lasciar perdere la tinta labbra scura e
mentre magari news oppure fare la stessa
cosa però con gli occhi quindi magari
truccare un po di meno gli occhi e
spararvi la tinta labbra bella rosso
scuro siamo subito al terzo ed ultimo
make up
iniziamo subito dagli occhi vanno nostri
atleti andiamo subito sull'oscuro quindi
su questo melanzana applichiamo per bene
sulla palpebra fissa scendendo anche un
po su quella mobile
questo melanzana un po è un po satinato
effettivamente picco una volta finito
questo passaggio passiamo alla parte
diciamo un po sperimentale di questo
make up come ho fatto prima con la tinta
labbra oro
adesso utilizzerò questa qui e vediamo
cosa viene fuori
io
procediamo con l'altro occhio non è
finita qui perché mi aiuta un'idea
dell'ultimo minuto che voglio provare
speriamo di non fare
prendiamo questo viola glitterato lo
applichiamo un po qua
io no passiamo al nostro eye liner
passiamo al mascara quindi sempre il
nostro premier
in questo trucco mi metterò le ciglia
finte quindi io di solito passo prima il
mascara e poi prosegue con le cig
azienda possiamo passare alle ciglia
finte che vi dico la verità non metto da
una vita perché ho usato un prodotto che
mi ha fatto crescere le ciglia in
maniera incredibile magari un giorno me
ne parlerò
o siamo un po di mascara chiaramente
anche su pc via finte e devo dire che
l'effetto grafico che per quanto
riguarda la le labbra vorrei iniziare
con un contorno del colore appunto che
ho applicato anche sulla palpebra mobile
una roba del genere per poi applicare
invece facciamo nelle parti che hanno
lasciato senza colore è una tonalità un
po più chiara io metterò besta
coop
adoro ma visto che questo è il carnevale
di rio anzi come ho detto prima il
natale a rio non sono ancora soddisfatta
voglio aggiungere ancora dello
sberluccicanti utilizzerò questi
brillantini adoro no vabbè una sola
parola la sobrietà prima di tutto c'è
questa cosa dei brillantini e lavoro
siamo giunti purtroppo alla fine del
video spero tantissimo che vi sia
piaciuto lo aspettavate tanto quindi
turn over deluso le vostre aspettative
come al solito se vi è piaciuto
mettetevi un bel live che se non l'avete
ancora fatto iscrivetevi al canale e
seguitemi su tutti gli altri social
facebook in forme musicali io adoro ciao
ragazzi